OK, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I really like this voicemail, as many of you
know, and we covered it.
Earlier today, Donald Trump was caught on
an audio recording of a phone call with the
Georgia secretary of state asking them to
find him.
Eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty votes,
which would give him a win in Georgia over
Joe Biden.
Now, even if they did that, it wouldn't flip
the results of the election because Joe Biden
won enough other states to win anyway.
But this caller points out something sort
of tongue in cheek but that we are hearing
who recorded the call.
It was illegal to record the call.
That's the focus.
Take a listen.
Hi, David.
So, yeah, everyone's talking about this phone
call, and I just want to say I think it was
absolutely perfect.
There was absolutely it was a perfect phone
call.
There was nothing wrong with it.
Perfect.
There should be doing some investigations
for illegally recording it, right?
Yeah, illegally recording a private phone
call is just.
Yeah.
So I get that they're joking, but there's
a few things here to talk about, number one,
both side, you know that I don't both sides,
almost anything.
Both sides mostly play this game when there
is a leak and they like the content of the
leak.
They focus on the content and they ignore
how it was obtained.
When they don't like the content of the leak,
they say, whoa, hold on a second, that was
illegally recorded or it was leaked by someone
who didn't have access to it or whatever.
Democrats and Republicans really both do this
almost to the same degree.
And it's one of the areas where there really
is very little difference between Democrats
and Republicans.
However, what is interesting is that presumably
Donald Trump well, we know Donald Trump was
in Washington, D.C. when this call was made
and Brad Raffensperger was in Georgia when
this call was made.
Both Georgia and D.C. are to our one party
consent territories, meaning it is legal to
record a phone call as long as someone on
the call knows that it's being recorded.
The question is, if the people who were doing
the recording and knew it was being recorded
were in Georgia and no one in D.C. knew it.
I am not a lawyer, as many of you know.
My question would be, does D.C. law about
one party consent mean that at least one party
in D.C. needs to know that it's being recorded
for it to be legal?
I don't know the answer to that.
And these one party versus two party consent
things, when you have different laws in different
states, when the two states on a call have
different laws, this becomes a federal issue.
And anyway, it's kind of a whole bigger topic,
but it may not actually have been an illegal
recording here.
It's quite possible because both territories
are one party consent that this was actually
perfectly legal to record, assuming some of
the parties on the call were the ones doing
the recording.
We don't have that information yet.
I am sure that one of the many lawyers in
the audience will clarify this for me.
But yes, we should be outraged.
Not that Trump is openly pressuring people
to steal the election.
We should be outraged that this was recorded.
Give me a break, guys.
Come on.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will hear about our New Year's vacations,
which were for me anyway, very boring.
We will look back at 20 covid insurance lawsuits.
Very interesting.
We'll talk about new food waste laws in China.
And Donald Trump is set to award Medals of
Freedom to cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
Congressman Devin Nunes.
And Jim, I almost said Jim Schwartz, Jordan,
Jim Jordan.
OK, why?
I'll tell you on the bonus show, get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a member
of Join Pakman Dotcom.
And remember that we are hoping for a better
twenty twenty one and you can use the coupon
code better 21 to get a big discount off of
the membership of your choice at Join Pakman
Dotcom.